it was a triumphant day for horse
disable pop the Bavarian State premier
has led his party back from the severe
blow five years ago to an overall
majority the CSU no longer needs a
coalition partner the sustained cause
arteaga wall of this is a magnificent
success the CSU is alive and well and is
a true party of the people we have deep
roots here one in two Bavarians voted
for us the CSU gained votes at the
expense of the Free Democrats the fdp
will leave the government and the state
parliament to the social democrats had
hoped for more but their lead candidate
tried to put a positive spin on things
as Islam the Svea owns a teal Nick it's
true we didn't achieve our goal but
there is encouraging news because we
attracted more votes for the first time
for a long time you can't take that for
granted you've been in contin came at
six to implicate parties left-of-center
had a poor day the Greens lost ground
and pulled about one percent lower than
in 2008 we're disappointed but we'll do
all we can in the state of Hessen and
the national elections english tongue
bundestag spot the free democrats are
also focusing on next sunday's general
election the olive isn't we know that
it's a different ball game in bavaria
but now it's about germany this is a
wake-up call for all liberals assign
vehicles for Allah libre holland the ftp
must now wait and see whether it
attracts the five percent support needed
to return to the national parliament